[Musique]
la question est simple et elle tient en
deux mots pourquoi vivre
pourquoi vieux pourquoi toute cette
agitation dans laquelle nous sommes
engagés
jour après jour bon gré mal gré au
travail à la maison toutes ses
obligations à remplir toutes les
frustrations à supporter tous ces mots à
soigner tous ses loisirs à consommer
toute cette routine que nous suivons un
peu comme des automates
alors je sais ce que vous pensez vous
vous dites c'est un peu idiot de se
poser la question puisque nous le sommes
déjà envie oui mais qui est ici
prétendre qu'il ou elle ne s'est jamais
posé la question à jour est sûre c'est
une question universelle qui depuis des
millénaires entre nos congénères
l'animal doté de langage et de
conscience quel être humain peine à être
sur cette terre sans se poser la
question du pourquoi de son existence
parce que la question
sous ses airs simple est en réalité
complexe
il a fallu inventer des trucs pour
prétendre d'avoir résolu
alors quel truc des religions les
oeuvres d'art des idéologies voire même
des systèmes de destruction massive des
modèles entier de civilisation se sont
développés pour substituer à cette
incertitude l'ordre et l'organisation
aci en donnant à chacun la possibilité
d'appartenir à un système
la question semblait résolu
et pourtant elle demeure tapis dans les
recoins de nos inquiétudes de nos nuits
blanches tenace choléra nous un peu
commun la coquille sur l'escargot alors
pourquoi vivre pour manger dormir
subsister vivre pour se maintenir en vie
c'est un peu ennuyeux un peu limité
vivre pour se reproduire pour perpétuer
l'espèce or comme nous l'avons vu un
nous sommes déjà plus de 6 milliards
d'individus sur cette petite terre et
nos ressources s'épuisent à vue d'oeil
et puis dans ce cas les gens qui n'ont
pas d'enfant comme moi n'aurait rien à
faire ici vivre pour s'aimer oui alors
l'amour va et vient il n'est pas
toujours au rendez-vous de toutes nos
années vivre pour découvrir de nouveaux
territoires révolutionné la science
améliorer le lot commun de l'humanité
mais où tous ici ne sommes pas capables
d'énoncer la théorie de la relativité ou
d'inventer l'intelligence artificielle
et pourtant nous sommes là mais
peut-être est-ce une mauvaise idée que
de s'interroger rhin si vous en êtes
rendu compte la question est une
question piège qui plus on la creuse
plus elle ouvre une succession de
suppositions une mise en abyme un peu
vertigineuse car jamais elle ne trouve
de réponse assez satisfaisante à ces
définitive
pourquoi vivre
il fut une période de ma vie il y à peu
près dix ans de cela où chaque soir et
chaque matin au plus tôt l' inverse
chaque matin et chaque soir et même
plusieurs fois par jour je me suis posé
cette question ce n'était pas une
question subsidiaire une question
théorique comme elle est ici ce soir
mais une question obsédante urgente un
impératif aussi bien émotionnel
qu'intellectuel donc tout semblait
dépendre et mon incapacité à sentir que
je possédais la réponse à cette question
m'empêcher de vivre pire mon incapacité
à croire en les réponses que je pouvais
lui donner failli mettre un terme à
cette vie dont je ne cessais de
questionner le but est l'utilité c'est
un peu comme de réfléchir dans un jeu
d'adressé où l'on finit par perdre
justement parce que l'on a trop réfléchi
alors peut-être vous êtes nombreux ici
aujourd'hui à penser que vous avez la
réponse à cette question et après tout
c'est bien normal puisque vous avez
passé un certain nombre d'années vous
avez utilisé vos expériences à façonner
les motifs de votre vie et d'ailleurs
c'est peut être cela aussi vivre c'est
s'inventer des raisons de vivre
mais lorsque les raisons qu'on s'est
donné un beau jour paraissent
fallacieuse illusoire alors on se
retrouve face à cette énigme
on se retrouve face à cette question
existentielle
on se retrouve au bord de ce que l'on
appelle la dépression si j'insiste sur
cette question ce soir
si j'insiste sur cette question pourquoi
vivre c'est pour essayer de vous faire
comprendre la différence entre une
personne qui est en dépression est une
personne qui ne l'est pas pour une
personne qui n'est pas en dépression
cette question se pose rarement voire
quasiment jamais alors que pour une
personne qu'il l'est non seulement elle
se pose constamment mais elles ne
trouvent jamais de réponse valable
et si j'insiste sur cette différence
c'est parce qu'elle est souvent mal
comprise j'entends par exemple des gens
me dire peut-être que je suis en
dépression et que je ne le sais pas oui
alors s'imaginer en dépression quand on
ne l'est pas c'est un peu comme de
fermer les yeux pour se dire qu'on est
aveugle
cela n'a rien à voir on peut aussi être
en dépression sans l'avoir identifié
mais dans ce cas on sent que la fameuse
question road
alors pourquoi vivent pas parce que
c'est mieux que d'être mans c'est sans
doute là la réponse la plus intelligente
à donner à cette question sauf que pour
certaines personnes comme moi un certain
moment cette réponse n'existe plus vivre
ne vaut pas mieux que mourir alors c'est
une belle journée d'été je suis à la
campagne il y a des deschamps
merveilleusement vers une lumière
éclatante en ciel parfaitement bleu des
fleurs splendide et pourtant je ne vois
rien je ne sens rien de tout cela je
suis absorbé par l'espèce de trous noirs
qui creuse en moi et qui absorbe toutes
les pensées un tant soit peu
réjouissante qui me traverse je suis
dans une voiture celle de ma mère qui
conduit sur une route nationale et dans
quelques instants je vais ouvrir la
portière et sauter alors en matière de
tentative de suicide je ne vous
recommande pas de sauter d'une voiture
en marche non seulement parce que il ya
peu de chances de réussir mais en plus
parce qu'on devient un danger pour les
autres
et pourtant je les fais bien que j'ai eu
terriblement peur de mourir mais je les
fais parce qu'à cet instant cela me
semblait la seule délivrance à la
souffrance parce que la souffrance
contrairement à la mort vous tue à petit
feu
le problème avec le terme souffrance et
qu'il est appliqué un peu à toutes
sortes de douleur et le problème avec la
souffrance de la dépression c'est
qu'elle est presque indescriptible
ce n'est pas une douleur physique au
sens littéral du terme c'est à dire
qu'il ya pas de radio il n'y a pas de
scanner pour la localiser c'est plutôt
si j'essaye de la décrire une une sorte
de plaies émotionnel profonde qui se
rouvrent à chaque tentative de
cicatrisation le plaisir le plaisir et
le bond que nous appliquons sur nos
peines et nos angoisses pour les
atténuer
sauf que dans la dépression le plaisir
ne vient plus et sans ce plaisir la
souffrance se répand et se nourrit de sa
propre propagation qu'à force de se
propager
eh bien il finit par détraqué certains
métabolisme cérébraux il ya certaines
coordination entre le corps et le
cerveau qui ne se font plus et la pensée
en quelque sorte
si je peux dire abandonne le corps comme
un vieux chien sur le bord d'un fossé et
l'on a beau essayer de trouver les
appuis habituel il n'existe tout
simplement plus alors on est en vie et
non les plus vivants notre coeur bat nos
poumons se gonfle ou fonctionne mais nos
sentiments sont biaisés nos sensations
sont inexistantes
la mémoire est défaillante le regard
cloîtrés et l'espoir aux abois
pour ceux qui ont eu la chance de ne pas
la connaître la dépression est à mon
avis presque inconcevable
ce que j'ai vécu pour ma part dépasse
surpasse tout ce que je pouvais en
imaginé auparavant avant d'avoir connu
la dépression
la dépression est souvent vu comme un
état d'âme en spleen en manquent de
détermination ou un égocentrisme
exacerbé ou un apitoiement sur soi est
dépression et j'insiste sur ce point est
une maladie et comme toutes les maladies
comme tous les handicaps on en comprend
l'hégémonique une fois que l'on y est
confronté c'est un peu comme le deuil
d'un père ou d'une mère dont on dont on
ignore l'impact tant qu'on ne l'a pas
supporté
et j'insiste sur cette ignorance parce
qu'elle est la source de nombreux
préjugés dans le monde plus de 300
millions de personnes aujourd'hui
souffrent de dépression 300 millions le
ms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
estime qu'en 2020 c'est à dire dans deux
ans un peu moins la dépression sera la
deuxième cause de mortalité dans le
monde après les maladies
cardiovasculaires
déjà aujourd'hui huit cent mille
personnes se suicident par an
et pourtant la dépression demeure un
tabou quelque chose que l'on préfère
tenir caché par peur d'être stigmatisés
pour toujours et c'est un risque
effectivement puisque certaines
personnes pensent encore que la
dépression est une faiblesse de
caractère comme mon oncle par exemple
qui me répétait lorsque j'étais en
dépression alors mais tu t'écoutes trop
tu t'écoutes trop un jour j'ai fini par
lui dire que ce n'est pas que je
m'écoutais trop c'est que je ne
m'entendais plus et puis il ya ceux qui
pensent que la dépression est un défaut
de compétence comme ce drh qui lors d'un
entretien d'embauché
me demanda si ma dépression n'allait pas
saper la légitimité auprès de mes
collègues
ce à quoi je réponds dit que l'épreuve
de la dépression allait bien un diplôme
il ya ceux enfin qui pensent que la
dépression est un déficit de volonté
comme cet ami qui me dit que j'étais
seul à pouvoir m'en sortir puisque tout
dépendait de moi tout dépend des deux
mois mais qui était ce mois pour
s'infliger un tourment c'est cruel
il devait être plutôt sadique mais je me
suis dit qu'il valait sans doute mieux
penser que ce puits de souffrance que
j'étais devenu ne reflétaient aucunement
les aberrations et les défaillances de
mon environnement
la dépression ne ne s'arrête pas du jour
au lendemain il faut la combattre et
pour la combattre aucune aide n'est
superflu contrairement à ce que pensent
et mon mon ami
même s'ils ne comprennent pas très bien
notre état nos proches les gens qui nous
entourent peuvent être par leur présence
leur sollicitude leur amour leur humour
un signal un signal d'un possible retour
à la normale
en pleine mer en pleine nuit ce phare
que nous voyons au loin nous indique
qu'à cet endroit existe la terre ferme
le phare n'est pas une bouée il n'est
pas un canot de sauvetage
mais pourtant le voyons nous allons
continuer à nager et nous n'allons pas
nous noyer et progressivement mètre
après mètre
nous allons regagner la rive et nos
proches comme ce phare nous indique la
bonne direction parce que dans la
bataille qui s'engage contre la
dépression ce don selon manque ce dont
on l'on manque le plus cruellement c'est
deux points de repère ce n'est pas que
l'on ne veut pas agir mais les actions
envisagées par s inconséquente inutile
c'est un peu comme si notre paysage
intérieur avait été rasée tout y est
plat tout si vos tout y est figé c'est
un peu comme une plaine aride sur
laquelle plus rien ne peut pousser ce
n'est pas que l'on ne veut pas aller
mieux
il ya des gens qui me disaient cela tu
ne veux pas aller mieux ce n'est pas que
l'on veut pas aller mieux bien sûr bien
sûr que l'on voudrait aller mieux mais
non ne sais pas comment on ne sait pas
comment trouver les chemins pour
contourner son indifférence les tours de
passe-passe pour transformer le
désespoir en émerveillement en chacun de
nous vous l'avez peut-être remarqué vite
un ce que j'appelle un alchimiste il par
le pouvoir de l'imagination peut redorer
notre univers cet alchimiste est capable
de révéler le comique de nos déceptions
il est capable de redonner des couleurs
à notre avenir
mais quand cet alchimiste perd son
pouvoir
que se passe-t-il
la cible favorite de la dépression la
capacité à laquelle elle s'attaque en
premier et les magic nation dans la
dépression l'imagination c'est un on
imagine plus ce que l'on pourrait faire
ce que l'on pourrait être ce que l'on
pourrait vouloir ou désiré on imagine
plus rien parce qu'elle est un
ressassement morbide il est tentant
d'assimiler la dépression à une maladie
mentale à une maladie de la tête alors
que c'est le corps entier qu'elle rend
impotent c'est le corps aussi qui en est
la victime parce que parce qu il maigrit
parce que il se fatigue parce qu'il perd
son énergie et pour ma part c'est le
jour où j'ai compris que je devais
regagner mon corps que malgré les on a
commencé essayez de trouver des raisons
de la dépression des raisons de vivre ne
m'avait amené qu'à tourner en rond je
devais sortir de ma tête de mes
ressassement de mai amertume de mes
regrets pour regagner ce corps lui
redonner vie et me consacrer à lui un
peu communs comme le ferait une athlète
la sagesse populaire veut que ce soit
les gens les rater ceux qui n'ont pas
une chance dans la vie qui tombe en
dépression
mais rien n'est plus faux vous pouvez
aller sur wikipédia il y a une page sur
laquelle il ya une liste de personnes
célèbres de personnalités célèbres donc
notre ni trop raté est plutôt gâtés qui
connaissent ou ont connu une dépression
et parmi eux il y à un homme qui a
accompli une prouesse dont peu d'entre
nous peuvent se vanter il a marché sur
la lune
vous reconnaîtrez que
ceci nécessite une certaine
détermination et résistance
et pourtant buzz aldrin le deuxième
homme à avoir marché sur la lune
quand ils rentrent admission tomba en
dépression il avait réalisé son rêve
il était un héros aux états unis la
dépression sévit dans tous les milieux
dans toutes les classes sociales et même
si certaines personnes ils sont
prédisposées génétiquement elle peut
toucher n'importe qui même dire
n'importe qui sans raison
oui je le crois sans raison immuable et
déterminante parce que la dépression n'a
pas de raison elle n'a que des facteurs
favorisant un licenciement un accident
grave un deuil peuvent évidemment créer
un terrain favorable mais il ne
conduiront pas nécessairement à la
dépression il ya un poète que vous
connaissez peut-être peut-être qui
s'appellerait une aire maria rilke qui a
dit cette chose sur la dépression la
dépression n'a pas de particularité
déterminante
elle adopte les particularités de ce que
l'attak vous connaissez peut-être aussi
l'histoire du pont de base chaîne c'est
un pont près d'angers qui en 1850 s'est
écroulé au moment où le 3ème régiment
d'infanterie légère y défiler par le
poids des soldats étaient bien
inférieures à la résistance du pont et
pourtant le pont s'est écroulé pourquoi
il s'est écroulé parce que la cadence de
la marge des soldats a créé une onde
sonore qui est entré en résonance avec
le tablier du pont qui alors s'était
brûlé c'est une concordance de fait qui
entrant en résonance avec une faiblesse
singulière de l'individu initie chez lui
la dépression alors la dépression appris
certaines choses
elle m'a appris aussi une chose
essentielle la culpabilité peut faire de
nous des esclaves qui ne savent même pas
par où part cela se passe leur chaîne
parce que c'est souvent avec nous mêmes
que nous sommes les moins tolérants et
la dépression devient dès lors une
prison à laquelle une voix à cruel nous
condamne un tombeau que nous préférons à
l'échec ou à l'impuissance
alors si je suis devant vous aujourd'hui
c'est en tant que rescapé de moi même je
ne suis pas morte mais une résistance a
disparu une résistance que je croyais
indispensable pour être moi même à mon
avis toute épreuve nous apprend que pour
ne pas succomber
il faut changer savoir comment et la
difficulté de quais l'attachement de
quelques croyances cher nous devons nous
dessaisir
comment consentir à perdre ceux dont la
perte nous semblaient jusque alors
insupportable il faut accepter de
devenir un peu une autre ou un autre
pour pouvoir se retrouver parce que la
meilleure façon que la vie est trouvée
pour se perpétuer
c'est l'adaptation alors je vous pose
une dernière fois la question pourquoi
vivre peut-être pour servir
d'inspiration à ceux qui à leur tour se
poseront la question
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]